THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
TONIGHT IN JUST FIVE DAYS
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
MAKE THAT CRITICAL
DECISION YOU WILL REHIRE
THE POLITICIANS WHO KEPT
YOU OUT OF WORK, KEPT YOUR
KIDS OUT OF SCHOOL, OPENED
BORDERS, EMPTIED PRISONS,
DISMANTLED THE POLICE,
DROVE INFLATION THROUGH
THE ROOF, A 40 YEAR HIGH,
OR SEND THEM PACKING, YOUR
CHOICE.
POLLS SHOW THE POSSIBILITY
OF A RED WAVE, BUT IT IS
NOT AT ALL CERTAIN, SO BE
CAREFUL.
IT IS NOT EVEN CLOSE.
I'M TELLING EVERYONE TO
ASSUME THAT EVERY SINGLE
RACE IS THAT CLOSE THAT
YOU, YOURSELF WILL BE THE
DECIDING VOTE.
ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN.
TURNOUT WILL BE KEY.
TAKE NOTHING FOR GRANTED.
AS OF NOW, NEARLY EVERY
MAJOR RACE IS DEAD EVEN IN
POLLS OR WITHIN ONE TO
THREE POINTS.
THAT INCLUDES THE LIVE
FREE OR DIE GREAT STATE OF
NEW HAMPSHIRE WHERE A
REPUBLICAN IS UP BY ONE IN
TWO BRAND NEW POLES.
STRAIGHT AHEAD, BUL
ALANCE
DUCK JOINS US.
WE HEAR FROM SOUTH
CAROLINA SENATOR ON THIS
RACE AND OTHERS, TIM
SCOTT, AND NEW MEXICO,
THEIR GUBERNATORIAL
CANDIDATE MARK RON HIGH
TEMPERATURE OH, POLLING
NECK IN NECK WITH THE
STATE'S DEMOCRATIC
INCUMBENT.
WE WILL CHECK IN WITH
CARRIE LAKE AND BLAKE
MASTER'S TOGETHER IN
ARIZONA.
THE SENATE RACE IN THE
GREAT STATE OF ARIZONA IS
TIED, ACCORDING TO NEW
INSIDER ADVANTAGE POLL.
I HAVE TO IMAGINE IT WILL
MEAN SOMETHING THAT THE
LIBERTARIAN BAILED OUT, IN
PENNSYLVANIA, LESS THAN A
POINT SEPARATES DR. OZ AND
THE TRUST FUND BABY BRAT
IN A HOODIE FETTERMAN.
IN NEVADA, A TWO POINT
RACE, IN GEORGIA LESS THAN
A POINT, IN NORTH
CAROLINA, IT IS ABOUT
FIVE.
AND WISCONSIN, ANYWHERE
FROM THREE TO FIVE.
HIGH SCHOOL SAME THING,
BETWEEN THREE AND FIVE.
LET ME PUT IT THIS WAY.
IT IS LIKELY LESS THAN
100,000 VOTES FROM ALL
THESE STATES COMBINED WILL
DECIDE THE BALANCE OF
POWER IN THE U.S. SENATE,
AND RIGHT NOW, THERE'S NO
REASON TO CELEBRATE.
THESE RACES COULD GO
EITHER WAY.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER THREE
STATES IN 2016 COMBINED
MADE THE DIFFERENCE,
77,000 VOTES THAT PUT
DONALD TRUMP OVER THE TOP,
AND IN 2020, THREE STATE,
43,000 VOTE MADE THE
DIFFERENCE FOR JOE BIDEN.
NO ONE CAN PREDICT WHAT
WILL HAPPEN COME ELECTION
DAY, BUT I KNOW THE
DEMOCRATS ARE RUNNING VERY
SCARED.
WE KNOW TONIGHT WE ARE
WITNESSING FULL ON STATE
OF PANIC ON THE LEFT, AND
THERE WAS NO PANIC WHEN
GAS PRICES WERE SPIKING OR
WHEN INFLATION WENT
THROUGH THE ROOF,
SUPPOSEDLY TRANSITORY.
THEY TOLD US IT WASN'T A
BIG DEAL.
FOR MONTHS THEY DIDN'T
KNOW THERE WAS A BABY
FORMULA SHORTAGE.
THEY FREQUENTLY ACCUSE US
OF OVERREACTING TO VIOLENT
CRIME, CRT, AFGHANISTAN,
THE BORDER CRISIS,
FENTANYL CRISIS, YET
THEY'RE TOTALLY UNBOTHERED
BY ANY OF THE VERY REAL
PAIN AND SUFFERING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE NOW
FACING.
70% OF AMERICANS FULLY
LIVING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK, BARELY MAKING
ENDS MEET.
MANY OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE
NOT MAKING END MEET, AND
JUST FOR BARE NECESSITIES
THEY ARE SPENDING ON A
CREDIT CARD.
ALL FACED WITH THE REAL
POSSIBILITY OF LOSING AN
ELECTION, DEMOCRATS ARE
CLAIMING THE SKY IS
FALLING, DEMOCRACY IS IN
PERIL, AMERICA ITSELF IS
DOOMED.
HIGH IN THEIR IVORY TOWER.
LIBERALS SEEM TO BELIEVE A
REPUBLICAN MAJORITY IN THE
HOUSE OR SENATE IS THE
GREATEST THREAT KNOWN TO
MAN, AND BY THE WAY, THE
ONLY WAY TO SAVE DEMOCRACY
IS TO VOTE FOR THEM.
AGAIN, AND GIVE THEM MORE
POWER.
POWER IN PERPETUITY.
ONE PARTY RULE FOREVER AND
EVER, AMEN.
DOES THAT SOUND LIKE
DEMOCRACY TO YOU?
DOESN'T TO ME.
RIGHT ON CUE BIDEN
DECLARING THE MEGA MAGA
REPUBLICANS ARE A THREAT
TO THE REPUBLIC.
TODAY HIS BRAINLESS CHIEF
OF STAFF, RON KLAIN,
REFERRED TO THE SPEECH AS
JOE'S FINAL WARNING TO THE
COUNTRY.
I HOPE YOU WERE WATCHING.
>> THE PRESIDENT DECIDED A
FEW DAYS AGO IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO ISSUE ONE
FINAL WARNING ON THIS
ISSUE, TO MAKE VERY CLEAR,
TO LEAVE NO DOUBT THAT WE
HAVE PEOPLE OUT THERE
STILL PEDALLING THE BIG
LIE, PEOPLE NOW RAISING
THE ISSUE OF ELECTION
DENIAL IN THIS ELECTION,
AND OF COURSE THE HORRIBLE
INCIDENT INVOLVING SPEAKER
PELOSI AND HER FAMILY, YOU
KNOW, SHOWING THE RISING
THREAT OF POLITICAL
VIOLENCE, SO I THINK ALL
THOSE THINGS CAME TOGETHER
AND LED THE PRESIDENT TO
MAKE THE STRONG REMARKS HE
MADE LAST NIGHT.
>> Sean: THAT STACEY
ABRAMS NEEDS TO STOP THAT.
I AGREE.
FINAL WARNING, RISE OF
POLITICAL VIOLENCE BECAUSE
OF REPUBLICANS?
WE HAVE BEEN CONSISTENT.
WE CONDEMN ALL VIOLENCE,
CONDEMNED IT REAL TIME ON
JANUARY 6th, CONDEMNED IT
ALL THROUGH THE SUMMER OF
2020, 574 RIOTS, DOZENS OF
DEAD AMERICANS, THOUSANDS
OF COPS INJURED.
WE HAVE ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
REPUBLICAN HOUSE CANDIDATE
IN NORTH CAROLINA, HE JUST
HAD HIS HOUSE SHOT UP.
LOOK AT THAT RIGHT THERE.
BULLETS INTO HIS HOME
AFTER HIS DEMOCRATIC
OPPONENT FEATURED THE
HOUSE IN A CAMPAIGN AD.
AND LAST NIGHT SOMEONE
TRIED TO ACOST GENERAL
BOLDOCK.
EARLIER, A MAN TRIED TO
STAB LEE ZELDIN, GOING FOR
HIS CAROTID ON STAGE.
A MAN ASSAULTED RAND PAUL.
DERANGED BERNIE SANDERS,
RACHEL MADDOW SUPER FAN
SHOT UP A BASEBALL FIELD,
NEARLY KILLED STEVE
SCALISE, AND UNLIKE THE
DEMOCRATS, I DON'T BLAME
BERNIE SANDERS OR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY FOR ANY
OF IT, BUT POLITICAL
VIOLENCE IS NOT THIS ONE
SIDED REPUBLICAN ISSUE.
THERE ARE PSYCHOS IN BOTH
PARTIES AND SHAMEFUL
DEMOCRATS ARE SMEARING
CONSERVATIVES FOR A CHEAP
POLITICAL WIN BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T RUN ON ISSUES THEY
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL AT.
INSTEAD OF CONDEMNING ALL
VIOLENCE, BLAME
REPUBLICANS.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY ON THE
LEFT HAVE TOTALLY LOST
TOUCH WITH REALITY.
YOU WANT CASE IN POINT,
LISTEN TO THE OFFICIAL
PRESIDENTIAL HISTORIAN FOR
NBC NEWS, CHICK LITTLE
HIMSELF.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HISTORIAN 50 YEARS FROM
NOW, IF HISTORIANS ARE
ALLOWED TO WRITE IN THIS
COUNTRY, IF THERE ARE FREE
PUBLISHING HOUSES AND FREE
PRESS WHICH I AM NOT
CERTAIN OF, IF THAT IS
TRUE, A HISTORIAN WILL SAY
WHAT WAS AT STAKE TONIGHT
AND THIS WEEK WAS THE FACT
WHETHER WE WILL BE A
DEMOCRACY IN THE FUTURE,
WHETHER OUR CHILDREN WILL
BE ARRESTED AND
CONCEIVABLY KILLED.
WE'RE ON THE EDGE OF A
BRUTAL AUTHORITARIAN
SYSTEM AND IT COULD BE A
WEEK AWAY.
>> Sean: HE IS TREMBLE
ING
WITH FEAR FROM HIS D.C.
MANSION.
HE CAN'T FATHOM WHY VOTERS
ARE WORRIED ABOUT
INFLATION, GAS PRICES,
VIOLENT CRIME, OPEN
BORDERS, AND THE LIKE,
WOKE EDUCATION.
KIDS AREN'T LEARNING TO
READ, WRITE, DO MATH,
SCIENCE, HISTORY AND
COMPUTERS.
AND CHICKEN LITTLE SO
PAINFULLY DETACHED FROM
REALITY IT SEEMS TO BE
ROTTING HIS BRAIN.
HE IS NOT ALONE.
SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY NOW
BELIEVE THE END IS NEAR.
THESE PREDICTIONS OF
REPUBLICAN WIN MEANS LIFE
AS WE KNOW IT IS OVER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DEMOCRACY IS IN DANGER
ALL OVER THE WORLD, HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES AS
WELL, BUT ALL OVER THE
WORLD, SECRETARY CLINTON.
>> THEY'RE PUSHING OUT ALL
THESE POLLS THAT MUDDY UP
THE AVERAGES AND SORT OF
CREATE THIS NARRATIVE OF A
RED WAVE.
IF IT DOESN'T HAPPEN,
AREN'T WE GOING TO BE IN
MORE DANGER OF VIOLENCE
BECAUSE THEY CREATED A
NARRATIVE AND IF IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN, THEY'LL
SAY THE WHOLE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN.
>> WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
TONIGHT IS THAT THERE IS A
SERIOUS CHANCE THAT IF
THIS DOESN'T GO WELL, WE
DON'T HAVE DEMOCRACY ANY
MORE.
>> FOR THE PRESIDENT AND
THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE
AMERICANS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, THERE'S STILL A
CONCERN ABOUT THE THREAT
TO DEMOCRACY ON MULTIPLE
FRONTS.
>> I THINK WHAT THE
PRESIDENT DID IS MOTIVATE
DEMOCRATIC BASE VOTERS WHO
QUITE RIGHTLY ARE WORRIED
ABOUT THE EXISTENCE OF OUR
DEMOCRACY IF THESE TRUMPY
ELECTION LIARS GET IN.
>> Sean: TRY TO KEEP
TRACK.
ACCORDING TO DEMOCRATS, IF
THE GOP WINS AN ELECTION,
DEMOCRACY WILL BE OVER,
CITIES WILL BURN, PEOPLE
WILL DIE, AND REPUBLICANS
WILL ABOLISH MEDICARE AND
SOCIAL SECURITY AND THEY
WILL DEFUND THE VA FOR
GOOD MEASURE.
>> THEY WANT TO GUT SOCIAL
SECURITY AND MEDICARE AND
THEN GIVE SOME MORE TAX
BREAKS TO THE WEALTHY.
>> EVERY YEAR CONGRESS
DOESN'T VOTE IT, IT GOES
AWAY, GONE.
YOU HAVE BEEN PAYING
SOCIAL SECURITY YOUR WHOLE
LIFE.
YOU EARNED IT.
NOW THESE GUYS WANT TO
TAKE IT AWAY.
WHO IN THE HELL TO THEY
THINK THEY ARE.
EXCUSE MY LANGUAGE.
>> IF YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT
THE ECONOMY, COST OF
LIVING, GETTING BY, THINK
OF WHAT IT WILL BE LIKE IF
THEY GO BACK TO HIGHER
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICES,
UNDO WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
DID, GO AFTER SOCIAL
SECURITY AND MEDICARE AND
PULL IT UP BY THE ROOTS.
THOSE ARE SERIOUS THREATS
TO ANYBODY.
>> Sean: I WILL GO BACK TO
GDP OF 1.4%, NOT 8.5, A 40
YEAR HIGH.
GO BACK TO $2 GASOLINE.
BACK TO SECURE BORDERS AND
BACK TO ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
I WOULD LOVE THAT.
WHAT THEY'RE DOING, OBAMA,
BIDEN, HILLARY, THEY'RE
MAKING IT UP.
IT IS DESPERATE FEAR
MONGERING, LYING,
MANIPULATING THE ELDERLY
AND SICK FOR VOTE THAT
SHOWS HOW DESPERATE
DEMOCRATS REALLY ARE.
THIS BIG LIE THAT
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO
CUT SOCIAL SECURITY AND
MEDICARE, THEY ROLL IT OUT
EVERY SINGLE ELECTION.
REPUBLICANS ARE RACIST,
SEXIST, HOMOPHOHOMOPHOBIC, ISLA
PHOBIC, TRANSPHOBIC.
NOW THEY WANT TO TAKE AWAY
GRANDMA AND GRANDPA'S
SOCIAL SECURITY AND THROW
THEM OVER THE CLIFF IN A
WHEELCHAIR.
THEY'VE BEEN USING THIS
FOR DECADES, REPUBLICANS
NEVER LAID A FINGER ON
MEDICARE OR SOCIAL
SECURITY.
NOT ONE REPUBLICAN SAID
THEY WOULD.
AND IT IS CLEAR DEMOCRATS
HAVE NOTHING POSITIVE TO
RUN ON.
THEIR AGENDA FAILED
MISERABLY.
THEY HAVE NO POSITIVE
STORY TO TELL AT HOME AND
ABROAD, AND AMERICANS ARE
NOW WORSE OFF BY EVERY
SINGLE MEASURE.
YET THEY'RE DEMANDING YOU
REWARD THEM AND REWARD
THEIR LIES AND THEIR
FAILURES.
AND YOU REWARD THE
HYSTERIA, VITRIOL.
IT IS ALL DELUSIONAL.
THANKFULLY IN FIVE DAYS
YOU HAVE THE POWER